they're saying it came from aliens where
did the aliens come from where did the
aliens get the quality of life oh they
got it from other aliens and where did
they get it from
listen if Islam subjugates women why is
the greatest number of converts to to
Islam in the first world countries
America Europe and so on well why why
are they predominantly women
[Music]
[Music]
greetings a peace welcome to the Dean
shell dr. Brown peace be with you
assalamu alaikum how you doin Salam good
thanks
what why do they call it new atheism is
something new that never existed let's
get right into the topic you've been
doing some wonderful work refuting it
but I want to start off with why do they
call it the New Atheism you know really
to be honest with you I just like to
call it what it is it's atheism new-old
whatever it's I mean what what is
particularly new about atheism I think
you know I'm not sure why they call it
the New Atheism but what I do know is
that the face of atheism has changed in
that whereas it existed in the past as
something quiet kind of quiet people
were atheist and I just sort of kept to
themselves now it has become almost
whole not almost or frankly evangelical
and in that they are calling people to
atheism they are advertising it they're
making aggressive campaigns to gather
people toward atheism and that is a
shift and that is something something
new and different yeah seems like they
have their atheist prophets now
proselytizing trying to win the hearts
to this belief that something came from
nothing that how does it go in a
nutshell hmm there were an accident
because by saying you're you're
basically an atheist you're just an
accident that happened purposeless
instead of purposeful can we say that
you're no I wouldn't look I mean if if
you look if you're asking me basically
what is the focus of a theist believes
it's exactly what you know a theism
means no God they they just simply
believe in that there is no God so if we
were eight years we'd be two accidents
well you know this is not exactly how
they see it but I mean they see it as
you know they see us as the process of
development from the beginning of the
universe with the Big Bang and then the
process of evolution through natural
selection you know it's basically a
their way of explaining of where we came
from yeah and the this is something
that I touched on on my talks called the
big questions the big questions these
are on my I've read those yeah yeah it's
in an article and it's in my on my
website as seriously what's your website
called people go to see that well it
uses level truth it used to be called
level truth calm and I was still called
level truth calm but it is being changed
to just my name dr. Lawrence Brown calm
or dr. ellby be calm so that's D r lb be
calm dr. Lawrence Brown if you didn't
know he is a former US Navy major was
Air Force Air Force Major was an atheist
tried very hard to be a Christian and
the link below will have his previous
show you also have a website that you're
talking about level truth that you're
changing it to binoculars Bach and
another thing I wanted to mention has a
PhD or as a doctor in divinity yeah okay
but you know I think it's I think it's
time to be clear about this I don't
value religious degrees at all I don't
I'm just saying you guys yeah okay I got
when you're an expert in comparative
religion well hey listen that's what a I
can introduce you hi Ron listen let's
get back let's not okay I'm gonna bow
out of this aisle saying no way I do I
don't want to make the point about this
okay yeah all right yeah I mean you can
say that I have these degrees personally
I consider religious degrees to be
basically worthless
anybody can get one well it's not quite
true you do have to work for you do
anyone can get a doctoral degree and I
surgeon be surgery and no of course not
but you know these are different things
yeah I mean I know what degree not in in
eye surgery is much more regulated there
are much more strict requirements no
listen just and you know just so you
know I mean pretty much anybody can go
on to the internet and get a doctorate
of divinity or become an ordained priest
I mean it's it's it's not particularly I
got to do and and the point I'm just
making is I don't care if you have
masters and a PhD I don't care if you
have 10 PhDs I don't care if it's from
you know the Istanbul School of Theology
and radiator repair or if it's from a
Harvard or Oxford okay it doesn't it
doesn't matter because this is not how
people choose religion people
choose religion by the smartest guy out
there with the with the best degree if
that were the case everybody would be
following the Pope or whoever you know
or you know whoever is considered to be
the most eminent theologian in the world
but that's not how people choose
religion whose religion people choose
religion by what makes sense to them and
what conforms to their template their
inner template of beliefs yeah
here this is something I can't wrap my
mind around maybe you can help us me and
others with this even if you are an
atheist and you argue evolution at a
micro level not a macro level whatever
the gate how do you get to the point
that there was an initiator who
initiated with the universe and
everything so what okay let's say
hypothetically evolution and man was a
some ape chimpanzee and out whatever and
you have faith in this how does that
still exclude God the Creator the
Almighty okay good question really great
question because here's the crux of the
matter
atheists explain the universe having
come into existence through the Big Bang
and they explain the diversity of
species through the you know the process
of evolution as a result of natural
selection okay now what I think you're
asking is basically referring to the
point that I made previously which is
how does that how does that contribute
to the Atheist debate why can't we
understand that the Big Bang and if
there were evolution by the process of
natural selection I'm not saying there
is I'm not saying there you know was or
that there wasn't I'm just saying that
if that is how the you know the
diversity of species developed why does
that change the debate why does that
mean that there's no God can't can't we
consider the possibility that God used
these devices as the process by which he
brought the universe into existence by
as the process by which he brought the
diversity of species into existence
it's very very very capricious to say
that because we think that we have you
know figured out how the Big Bang
happened and by the way you know we've
plotted some things back but the moment
of origin is a mystery but and you know
we think we understand how evolution
could have worked through the process of
natural selection okay so what so what I
mean can't aren't our minds large enough
to conceive of the possibility that our
creator created the Big Bang and then
exerted control over it too to keep it
you know basically from degenerating
into chaos can't we consider that the
process of natural selection is not a
random process but is rather the device
that our Creator used to bring out the
diversity of natural species so this you
know this argument doesn't doesn't work
in negating God but what it does work in
negating is certain religions when those
views do not conform with religion for
example as Muslims as Muslims our
scripture tells us that the universe is
expanding and continuing to expand and
is telling us that it was Allah that
expanded our universe and that it's
continuing to expand so we have no
problem with the Big Bang you know for
the religion of Islam these scientific
concepts can exist within our religion
you can be a Muslim and believe in the
Big Bang and you have no problem you're
just believing in the Big Bang is the as
the mechanism that our Creator put in
put into a place to bring the universe
into existence and it's the same thing
with the theory of evolution and natural
selection again whether you believe in
it don't believe in it doesn't matter
just doesn't matter because you can you
know as a Christian you might have
problems with it as a Muslim we have no
problem with it we just say a few
modifications you know we we believe
that the human being was a separate
creation separate from the animals did
not evolve from the Apes and certainly
if you believe in a God is
not within the realm of his capabilities
if you don't believe in a God okay well
this is different
but if you do believe in a God who could
create this universe and everything upon
it is it not within the realm of his
capabilities to create the human
organism mm-hmm
do you think what's pushed many people
towards this new atheism is the idea
that many people have of God this
fictitious character that's been created
in the minds of people like for instance
who we love dearly Jesus peace be on
people have made him a human being into
God people have made creation into God
but when you accept Islam we actually
start off with the proclamation there is
no God anything in creation except the
one who created creation who's outside
of creation do you think you get my
point that they go through it is towards
this because of all these human gods
that people have concocted these
fictitious gods like making Jesus peace
be upon him a mighty messenger who that
people take as a guide and other saints
and all these are the weird
superstitions and weird things that are
ascribed to to God okay you get me you
get my point
well I do and I mean actually and then
if people are just like this can't be
God this monkey or worshipping this Kyle
a human being that has a color a
nationality
you know walks on the earth goes to the
bathroom and then people just get turned
off by this ya know I get your point and
actually my daughter and I were just
talking about this today we had a very
nice conversation about this because you
know there you know that there are
another number of kind of relevant
quotes I mean one is that if God were
small enough to be understood he would
not be big enough to be worshipped okay
I mean it's kind of like that old
analogy about people examining an
elephant blindfolded and this was my
daughter's you know my daughter's
mentioned she was she was saying it's
kind of like that and I said yes it is
because you know one person one
blindfolded person feels the leg another
blind person blindfolded person feels
the ear another one feels the tail
another
feels the trunk and so they all come
away with a different concept of what an
elephant is hmm all right now if if you
never saw an elephant you would only
have that experience and you would feel
completely certainty that you know what
an elephant is all right but in fact
you've only had a very very small
exposure and so you're ignorant you you
really have no concept of what the
elephant is like as a whole well so it
is with our Creator our religion tells
us LASIK emitted Lahoma che there is
nothing like unto Him there if there is
nothing like unto Him there is nothing
in this worldly creation that we can use
as a reference by which to understand
him Allah may have a Facebook but it's
not like yours in mine because LASIK a
Mythili home shay there is nothing like
unto Him Allah may have a hand is it
like this hand of course not because
there is nothing like unto him nothing
nothing like his hand so so we we we
know that he has certain properties of
property if you know a mercy and love
and so on but and and we know he has
certain you know qualities but we cannot
quantitate or qualitative envision what
those things are mm-hmm okay now there's
there's just another thought which is
basically if our Creator were you know
with within our vision I mean if we were
able to see our Creator for our Creator
were small enough that we could see him
he would be an idol mm-hmm and you know
this is just another point you know the
atheist demand proof proof you know I
got to see God with my own eyes I mean
the show him show him to me
you know our show me proof of him which
is a subject we can come back to but you
know they they expect to want to be able
to see him with their own eyes well
whose rules are tit no all right now who
whose rules govern this universe I mean
if our Creator wishes for his
you know his existence to be shrouded in
mystery that's his decision not ours
yeah we're gonna take a break so you
could be honored with the title this is
sunt the son of Adam first man people
would take strong offense if you said
this is the the son of a monkey think
about that we'll be right back with more
of my special guests good friend dr.
Lawrence Brown no anywhere Salam says
love all mankind that's why we're
sharing this message because we want the
best for you and we want the best for
all mankind please subscribe to the
Biggio follow us on our official
Facebook and Twitter pages in the links
below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below
welcome back to the D show special guest
all the way from Medina dr. Lawrence
Brown what is the the crucial core
belief that most atheism hold on to and
if this belief is taken refuted that it
would just crumble
well a theme please atheism beliefs are
most atheist but the one core belief
okay well I mean obviously they believe
that there is no God and the argument
that's used to substantiate if this is
refuted everything crumbles right well I
mean there certainly are a number of
those I mean if you could disprove
evolution by the process of natural
selection if you could disprove the Big
Bang and so on the their scientific
frame of reference would disappear and
that's kind of a long discussion I think
actually we should come back to that but
I think the you know the bigger issue is
just that most atheists that I've known
their hearts and their minds are pretty
much sealed they're they're not they're
not willing to consider other
possibilities you know they're not even
willing to consider the possibility of a
god I think one point I would make is
that they have this you know they have
this saying it's called you know
Hitchens razor and it's basically a
theory that whatever can be proposed
without proof can can be negated without
proof you know what if you if you say
that there is a God and you don't have
proof then you can equally well say that
there's no God without proof okay and it
it's just kind of dancing around the
subject because you can just turn that
around well if you say there's no God
without proof then I can say that there
is a God without proof you know this is
this is a matter of belief it's a belief
system okay you either feel the presence
of God or don't or two to speak in even
more nonspecific terms
creator let's just talk about creator
yeah some people are upset even by the
Word of God you know the word God okay
and they rightly recognized that the
word God does not have any origin in
Scripture it is a name or a word of
uncertain origin it is nowhere in the
Bible okay I mean if you look at the
Bible and you know it's untranslated
language you'll not find God in the
Bible okay that's that's what we find in
our translations yes but not in the
original okay so in any case I mean the
point is just that they don't believe in
God that's that's their template okay
and and that's certainly where I was
when I was an atheist I experienced the
awakening of a feeling of the presence
of my creator what I did not experience
what was I did not experience a change
in my scientific convictions okay I I
believed in the Big Bang I believed in
in the the process of natural selection
and until this day I argue that you can
believe in those things and still be a
person of spirituality spirituality and
a person of religion now I tried very
hard I fought tried very hard to accept
the Jewish and the Christian religions I
tried very hard to understand them
enough to make sense of them and that
never worked for me okay and part of the
message that I'm trying to put out
that you know atheists have from what
I've seen they have a very very strong
hatred of Christianity or what it stands
for or its theology and they pick very
well upon you know inconsistencies
within the religion or hypocrisy x'
things the things that they can point to
and basically question how i mean where
does this tenant of faith come from
mm-hmm and and show precisely that you
know most most Christian beliefs
actually did not come from the teachings
of Jesus they come from the teachings of
Paul and who was the Prophet anyway you
know and and they can show that many of
the beliefs do not have a biblical basis
you know for example the Trinity is
nowhere in the Bible oh sure oh sure you
will find some things that you might
suggest it but look a little bit deeper
and you will find that you know that
these things many Bibles have taken them
out because they have been recognized as
inaccurate insertions they do not exist
in the foundational scripture they exist
in the translation but only because it
was a marginal note of a scribe that was
taken from the margin into the scripture
it was a note of a scribe it was not
Scripture okay so you know without
becoming preachy or going into a whole
big analysis you can you can look you
you can look at this up in my books on
my website again it's level truth calm
love of truth calm and that's changing
to dr. ellby be calm DRL be be calm but
you know read miss got it and you will
find all the information you want on
this subject and more there's a chapter
just on the Trinity and and many other
points of Christian theology that's not
the point point is this a lot of a lot
of atheists part of their atheism is
just an absolute disdain of Christianity
and the message I'm trying to get across
is well yeah there are other
out there who are very religious and I'm
talking about Muslims now they're very
religious and they're not Christian
they're Muslim and Islam has always been
a religion of science as well as
spirituality I mean we have to remember
that much of the roots of biology
physiology medicine chemistry physics
mathematics and so on grew up from the
Islamic religion the Islamic religion
encourages intelligence and
investigation and for us to know our
physical world and and so on so the
early the early Muslims experienced this
explosion and knowledge that led to the
first universities like the University
at Cordoba and so on would you know and
the centres of islamic knowledge became
known as the centres not only of you
know Islamic religion but also science
and learning and it was it was from it
was from these origins that so much of
science has grown yes so we because
that's what usually people think either
a like when you believe in God okay they
equate it with the tooth fairy or Santa
Claus or that you're anti science but
all along Islam actually when people are
in the dark ages Islam was actually
leading the way in science and it's
interesting because nowadays we see
science is figuring out the how of
things like you just were kind enough
out of your love you brought me a gift
of a Jew a date so if I was to take that
Edgewood date to a scientists the
scientists can give me the calorie
account he can give me all of the
intricate details the protein and
nutrition this vitamin this vitamin but
he can and and that's a beautiful thing
but just because we figure out the how
why do people stop there but that
scientists can never tell me who brought
me that date or the intention behind it
and why
so it's limited in the sense but that
doesn't mean we reject the how but it
seems like people now we know how
lightning strikes how the clouds come
just because we know the how people say
we figured it out we don't need God I
can't understand that well okay but
that's because you're religious that's
because you're spiritual and you know
and just to be clear you know I don't
think that they I don't think the
atheists demote the concept of a creator
to the truth fairy or Santa Claus except
in the sense that they basically say
that it is you know a belief in these
entities is the same it's without
foundation but there's a big difference
and that is that the Tooth Fairy doesn't
tell us that the Tooth Fairy exists
Santa Claus does not tell us that this
man glows but God does tell us that he
exists and if you are a person of
science science is a process of
investigation
now you might not be able to accept the
tenets of Christian faith I'm with you
there
I don't accept them either you might not
be able to accept the tenets of of
Jewish faith I'm with you I don't accept
them either but you should be able to
look back at these religions and
research them enough to find that there
is commonality of certain of certain
elements and so for example they all
teach monotheism at its core like I said
read my book it's free download from the
website you don't have to pay a cent but
you'll find that the New Testament does
not teach the Trinity the idea of the
divine sonship of Jesus Christ the you
know the idea of the laws having of the
laws of the religion having changed etc
etc etc these were all inventions that
were ushered in by other than Jesus
Christ okay if you read if you read the
Bible okay
looking just at the teachings of Jesus
Christ three times three times in the
Bible he's asked what is the greatest
commandment and he says no o Israel the
Lord your God is one God that is the
greatest commandment okay the the Lord
your God is is one now that's monotheism
so you have a common you have a common
thread through these religions from
Abraham to you know on up as male Isaac
how long would you say that would be a
10,000 years Jesus Moses okay just wait
let me finish that the the point being
there's commonality in the thread
there's commonality of Revelation okay
every time the revelation got corrupted
it was incumbent upon our Creator to
renew it so you have common you have
continuity in the chain of Revelation
and continuity in the chain of prophets
and one thing that stands out is through
all of these works the al-qaida or the
Creed remains the same the Creed of
monotheism the creative a prophet being
a man not a god
okay another you know another mistake
that is commonly made in Christianity so
you know all I'm saying is that if you
do your research you find that there are
commonalities which basically point to
an explanation for why there is a
continuity in the chain of Revelation
and continuity in the chain of prophets
which lead up to a final prophet and a
clarifying revelation yeah that's
remained unchanged unto this day and and
and and you don't have to separate
religion and science you do have to in
the religions with which it is not
compatible mm-hmm okay so Christianity
like I said you know you can't make
sense of the Big Bang and evolution in
the context of Christianity or Judaism
but you can in Islam because Islam is a
religion of science yeah how long would
you say how many over the span of how
many years thousands of years did this
chain of continuity the same message as
being delivered delivered from all these
proximately is that I somewhere around
ten thousand years from from when all of
the prophets were passing along this
message from one and it would have to be
from all these years from them I
couldn't even say because because you
know the original revelation was oral
yeah and and our creator tells us that
no population was left without you know
with without a messenger somebody bring
in yes so the point I'm trying to make
for all of these prophets that are still
known today messengers Moses Abraham
Jesus Solomon David Ishmael all of them
when you look back like you're saying
bringing the same message not a Trinity
not Christianity but submission to the
will of the creator
their followers and their followers it
seem like it's that's far-fetched that
they had conspired together to to this
day to bring that message that makes
that sense it fits make sense of it all
the purpose of life why we're here the
day of judgment and all of these things
if you ponder over it's things that are
good for Humanity good for society good
for yourself and you're not just an
accident that happened yeah okay granted
but we have to deal with what we have
again you know atheists are you know our
people who like to deal in logic they
like to deal in the things that we have
you know we have in our hands to hold
and that is the revelations we have we
can't really go back beyond that to sort
of make supposition about what the
prophets who are bearing the oral
messages we're teaching all we can say
is that our creator tells us that no
population was left without a messenger
and again this does make sense in the
continuity of the chain of Revelation
that at a time when there was no
communication between tribes and so on
wherever they were in the world our
Creator provided them with revelations
so that they had a chance to either
submit or not and thereupon they are
judged okay
but when mankind developed the facility
for recording the message in writing and
then developed communication between the
tribes and so on and so forth then this
process became a lot easier because once
a revelation was recorded that
revelation could be copied and passed on
to others but every time it became
corrupted okay every time it became
corrupted it was you know it was it
became incumbent upon the Creator to
renew the revelation so that he would
not leave us without guidance yeah Tim
you you mentioned logical I I don't I
don't agree there I think it's very
illogical that something would come from
nothing it's logical that a man wouldn't
be God that okay wait wait wait wait
let's come back to them yeah because
when you do talk to an atheist when you
really start getting deep got it got it
but I'm just I'm do they start becoming
illogical I'm just saying like we've got
what like two minutes left on this five
minutes we'll give you five minutes okay
this is just not going to work
I mean look and then they start talking
about UFOs and flying saucers and all
these straight undersurface it seems
logical but when you really start
dialoguing and talking it becomes really
illogical okay look if we've got five
minutes
talk to me tell me just talk to you
about one of those things but what I've
got to say yeah if you want to talk
about you know what atheists see as the
as the origin and how we came into
existence you got to give me more time
we got I do another episode so what you
just said about the aliens okay here's
one point there you know
the atheists are basically academic
they're intellectuals they like to think
that they have it all figured out but
there's one thing that they cannot
explain about the process of evolution
and via natural selection and that is
where the quality of life came from
scientists can Frankenstein together a
body of an animal or a human being
using perfectly functioning organs but
they can't make it live they cannot even
make you know a single-celled organism
live they cannot construct it they
cannot give it the property of life wait
wait a minute if Islam subjugates women
why is the greatest number of converts
to to Islam in the first world countries
America Europe and so on well why why
are they predominantly women that are
literally shocked to death or that think
about the animal that wills itself to
death all right I mean there's some
animals that mourn themselves to death
I had a cockatoo that when I when I gave
it to somebody else for for for
caretaking during my absence the
cockatoo died in two days it you don't
die from lack of food or lack of water
in two days this cockatoo was so sad
so saddened by my absence in the absence
of my family that it literally willed
itself to death now you think about
people who die from electrical shock
think about people who die from heart
attack okay some of them come back with
CPR but what about the ones who don't
come back with CPR we cannot bring those
bodies back to life so what is that
indefinable quality of life how does
natural selection explain that now
here's the point there's an old joke
about you know the scientist who is
giving it a talk about creation and
there's an old lady old old lady who
stands up in the audience afterwards you
know and she says oh you know really
you're so ignorant you're so ignorant
don't you know that this entire world is
balanced on the back of a giant turtle
and the scientist says oh ha ha you know
well tell me you know and tell me what
is the turtle standing on and the old
lady just looks at him and says you are
so stupid
you're so stupid it's Turtles all the
way down now everybody laughs what an
ignorant old lady it's Turtles all the
way down how silly okay fast-forward to
modern day okay you have a scientist
standing up on stage and he's talking
about the Big Bang is the origin of the
universe and evolution through natural
selection as the explanation for the
diversity of life as we know it today
ask him where the life came from you
know what their answer is now the most
common answer that they're giving now
they came from outer space once again
just like what we were talking about
that doesn't answer anything yeah
they're saying it came from aliens where
did the aliens come from where did the
aliens get the quality of life oh they
got it from other aliens and where did
they get it from what is the origin of
the aliens what's the origin of the
quality of life other aliens other
aliens other aliens now you've got these
so-called intelligent scientists looking
like this ignorant old lady in the
audience instead of saying that it's
Turtles all the way down there saying
it's aliens all the way up yeah now I
mean just think about that for a minute
these these are what I would call the
you know the ignorant intelligent people
yeah they're intelligent in a book
learned way but they haven't thought
their argument out and I think just to
set the record straight I mean there's
mainstream and I think many of these
kind of scientists have hide
act what we perceive now is today is
like the the view that if you're
scientists you can't believe in God but
I don't buy that because they're given
the mic but there are many scientists I
mean really proficient in their field
that they they're they're believers in
in in in in a creator that's there and
we usually when we link scientists we
think okay he's an atheist but no there
are many scientists they don't obviously
get that usually in the universities you
know because it's something in the
textbooks but there are many many
scientists who believe in a creator and
it's their work has led them to be
believed but they don't they're they're
not the ones that are given the the the
platform nowadays no there's been a big
resurgence in this I mean when I was in
college and we're going back to ancient
history now we're talking about like you
know thirty thirty some years ago when I
was in college basically all academics
all scientists were atheist and in the
short span of about forty years and the
short span about of yeah that's what it
is forty years you find now an
increasing number of scientists
believing in a creator and no no longer
able to discount a creator but able to
believe in a creator and to believe in
what science suggests such as the Big
Bang mm-hmm okay such as a diversity of
species able to believe in this in the
context of believing in a creator the
problem is the problem is that for most
of them they have they have trouble
reconciling their belief with the
creator with any established religion
they look at Judaism they say no that
doesn't work for us they look at
Christianity and they say no that
doesn't work either and they look at
Islam and then and they say well no
everybody knows that you know it's just
a bunch of terrorists so where am I left
I'm left as being a scientist with a
belief in God or is some of them embrace
Christianity just out of you know that's
the thing to do in in a predominantly
Christian country and they kind of sort
of force themselves and into the blue
the belief they're not comfortable with
it it's like putting a square peg into a
round hole but they can't find any
you know they can't find they can't find
that square hole to put their square peg
in they can't find a religion to conform
with their beliefs okay and the really
interesting thing I found about that and
there really isn't I mean look at the
YouTube videos look at any of the
lectures fought by these prominent
atheists whenever they criticize
Christianity they criticize it on the
basis of the tenets of faith and they
always show how they cannot accept these
tenets of faith and for good reason
for good reason the evidence is there
and again read my book you'll understand
why another thing is they never
criticize Judaism and as a matter of
fact many of them are strong supporters
of Israel figure that out I mean that
that that's very inconsistent with their
beliefs but that just is the way it is I
mean most of them do not they shy away
from criticizing Judaism I think largely
because they know that to do so will get
them into trouble and they know which
side their bread is buttered on when
they Chris criticized Christianity they
criticize completely on the basis of the
tenets of faith which they cannot yet
you know they cannot accept but when it
comes to Islam they don't touch the
tenets of faith because the tenets of
faith in Islam are not the issue for
them they always talk about deeply
emotional issues like you know they you
know Islam is just a bunch of terrorists
or they subjugate you know women wait
wait a minute if Islam subjugates women
why is the greatest number of converts
to to Islam in the first world countries
America Europe and so on well why why
are they predominantly women these are
not these are intelligent elegent women
becoming Muslim they're not they're not
stupid ignorant women these are
intelligent women with well-formed you
know opinions and so on who are becoming
Muslim as intelligent women why if
they're if Islam subjugates women why
would they do that ask them and you'll
find the answer
it's fine because Islam does not
subjugate women you know you know Islam
I mean many of them will tell you that
Islam sets them free but but the point
is that
while they are criticizing Christianity
on the basis of tenets of faith their
criticism of Islam is always on the
basis of the hot ticket issues that sort
of evoke emotions okay stop doing that
you're supposed to be an intelligent guy
you're supposed to be a man of academia
talk to me about Islam from the tenets
of faith
what objection do you have to believing
in God is one God
what objection do you have believing in
the continuity in the chain of
Revelation you know the prophets that
that that brought those books of
Revelation and a day of judgment heaven
hell angels what is your objection upset
except simply that you don't you don't
have the capability of seeing these
things you can't you know you can't have
them to to measure or quantitate you
can't scientifically prove them but tell
me what you know what objection do you
have to those tenets of faith now if
you're not able to answer that
now and don't talk about these other
things because you're not the rule maker
you're not the law maker mm that's where
our creator not you where can they get
in touch with you if they want to
continue to dialogue read some your work
we're out of time directors right my
main website which is level truth calm
and the name is changing to dr. LD be
calm doctor being dr lb be calm and
you'll find just a lot of information
there and my books are free downloads
thank you very much dr. Brown so it was
a pleasure and thank you for tuning in
to the D show subscribe if you haven't
right now like us follow us on the
facebook twitter and tune in every week
for a new exciting episode we'll see you
next time
peace be with you Islamic please
subscribe to the video follow us on our
official Facebook and Twitter pages in
the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below
[Music]